die Corona Maßnahmen angemessen oder
nicht im Pflicht ja oder nein überall
das dürfen wir streiten müssen wir
streiten ja aber mit Streit mit
Diskussion hat das immer öfter nichts
mehr zu tun was ich bei diesem
sogenannten korona.pos Spaziergänge
abspielt da wird provoziert und dann
vorallem attackiert es geht um Gewalt
immer wieder jetzt gezielt gegen unsere
Polizisten die müssen in dieser Corona
Krise ihren Kopf hinhalten
Montagabend in Sachsen ein sogenannter
Corona Spaziergang wieder fliegen die
Fäuste ungehemmte Aggression Ziel der
Gewalt die Polizei es sind Hooligans
rechtsradikale darunter auch immer
wieder Mütter mit Kindern oft als
Tarnung und menschlicher Schutzschild
eine perfide Taktik als die Polizei
einige Teilnehmer einkesseln will
eskaliert die Situation komplett es
regnet Flaschen und sogar Pyrotechnik
auf die Beamten zehn Polizisten erleiden
ein Knall tragen die Bedingungen für die
Beamten werden immer rauer dabei sind
die Bewerberzahlen ohnehin schon
rückläufig Beispiel Thüringen auf 300
freie Stellen kam 2010 noch dreitausend
Bewerber inzwischen sind es nur noch
sechs.
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem Chef
der Polizeigewerkschaft Rainer Wendt
schönen guten Tag Herr Wendt
sie ihre Polizisten ihr Beamten müssen
dafür ihren Kopf hinhalten wie sieht das
die Beamten Truppe selbst wie sehen dass
die Polizisten selbst
und das dritte ist die hohe
Gewaltbereitschaft einiger teilnehmenden
einiger Gruppen die das teilweise auch
organisieren aber die vor allen Dingen
mit Gewalt auf die Kolleginnen Kollegen
los gehen insgesamt soll jeder Staat
herausgefordert werden und darin besteht
die Schwierigkeit auch in der
Einsatzführung nämlich einerseits nicht
überzureagieren andererseits aber auch
nicht zurückzuweisen das darf der Staat
auch in dieser Situation nicht tun wenn
immer weniger Menschen junge Menschen
wollen zur Polizei wollen Polizisten
werden hat das auch was mit dieser
zunehmenden Gewalt zu tun
überhaupt bewerben können Eddy auf den
Markt drängt sie die Voraussetzungen
schon die formalen Voraussetzungen
erfüllen und drittens ist es natürlich
so dass wir sehr sehr sorgfältig
auswählen das heißt es kann nicht jeder
Polizistin oder Polizist werden und wir
wollen die Anforderungen auch nicht
senken es werden vielfältige Kompetenzen
gefragt um diesen Beruf auszuüben da
reicht es nicht in guter Sportler und
Sportlerin zu sein sondern viele
kommunikative psychologische auch
interkulturelle Kompetenzen sind gefragt
wir müssen wir ausbilden der Polizei und
die Voraussetzung dafür werden ihn
jeweils mehrtägigen
Verfahren geprüft bevor man jemanden
überhaupt einstellt und nicht jeder
schafft dann auch die aus
Sandra kannst du schon gesagt ihre
Beamten die Polizisten werden da zum
Teil gezielt gerade angegriffen auf die
Jagd gemacht gezielt angegriffen mit
Böllern mit Fäusten mit auch Waffen
teilweise fühlen sie sich fühlen sie
ihre Beamten ausreichend geschützt dort
in diesen Einsätzen
Gabi die sächsische Polizei das wandelt
Bilder die sie gezeigt haben hatte in
der Vergangenheit der Roland Villa der
Industrie in der Minister hat eine Menge
für eine Verbesserung der
Schutzausstattung der Ausrüstung der
Kollegin und Kollegen getan das muss man
einfach Geld nehmen konzedieren der
Arbeit die spiel cut besteht halt darin
dass nicht überall die Polizei bei jeder
Demonstration mit starken Kräften vor
Ort sein dann das ist eine besondere
Herausforderung da muss aus jedem
Einsatz wieder neu gelernt und die Lage
wieder neu beurteilt werden auf keinen
Fall darf es so sein dass wir uns doch
zurückziehen sondern im Gegenteil die
Polizei muss noch mit noch stärkeren
Kräften vor Ort sein damit solche Bilder
gar nicht erst entstehen sie sind aber
unvermeidbar wenn sich eine Lage anders
entwickelt als sie vorher beurteilt
worden wir unterstützen Sie Ihre Leute
denn auch psychologisch vor allem die
Gewalt erfahren das ist ja auch nicht
einfach zu verarbeiten für zum Teil auch
sehr sehr junge Menschen
verschiedene Möglichkeiten der Polizei
selbst hat auch die Polizei in Sachsen
mit kriseninterventionsdienst mit einem
Ausbau des sozialpsychologische
Betreuung der Einsatz könnte vieles
getan wie als Deutsche
Polizeigewerkschaft geben angeschlagenen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Möglichkeit
in unserer Stiftung in Bayern sich mal
zurückzulehnen und für einige Tage
auszuspannen das heißt es gibt schon
viele Möglichkeiten aber es ist auch
eine wichtige Führungsaufgabe solche
Einsätze dieses Gewalt geschehen dann im
Anschluss mit den Einsatzkräften
gemeinsam zu respektieren er auch immer
zu besprechen was man noch besser machen
kann aber vor allen Dingen auch sich mal
den Frust von der Seele zu reden
herzlichen Dank an den Chef der
Polizeigewerkschaft Rainer während ihr
bei Bild live über die eskalierende
Gewalt bei diesen sogenannten Corona
Spaziergänge